Surely there's nothing that can go wrong by building up years of hype before finally releasing a long anticipated sequel
I mean kingdom of the Crystal Skull lived up to everything Indiana Jones fans were hoping for
Independence Day resurgence
Zoolander two - the critics of all those movies agreed that the wait between movies was probably the best thing for the series right
Clearly I have nothing to worry about with this episode
Hello internet welcome to fiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiaa
Sorry my cat sat on the I key, so in last week's part 2 of this epic Whovian adventure
We continued our quest to lay out point by point the reasons why Time Lords could technically walk among us
Wait what you're saying it wasn't last week. You're telling me. It was two years ago. Nooo, no that doesn't sound right
Are you sure you didn't fall into a TARDIS or something?
Maybe you don't need proof the Time Lords exist because you are the Time Lord no, not buying it. Okay well
Here's the real story for those of you who haven't been subscribed since literally the day this channel launched
We've done to Doctor Who theories in the past the distant past the very far distant past the first two months of this channeled past
(Clears throat)
And if you haven't seen them you should probably go watch them now
I guess I don't know they were from the infancy of this channel who even knows what I was doing back in 2015
But this is a part three so did not at least help you find parts 1 & 2 of the series
78 videos later would be pretty mean of me you can find both of those in the I icon and upper right hand corner of the screen
Which begs the question of why did it take me over 2 years to release the third theory maybe I needed to do some
time-travel research of my own maybe the feds were trying to silence me about Time Lords
Maybe I'm working on launching a new theory Channel or maybe just maybe the script has been written the entire time
But I was never fully satisfied with the content contained in the episode not feeling
substantial enough for a
Full-fledged theory that would be believable to you guys could be any one of those who knows maybe I just leave that one up to you
Guys to theorize about but regardless the time is here now because enough people at VidCon Australia pestered me about it
And I can finally finally reveal to you all the truth Time Lords are...
Real there's not just evidence for one or two of them
Oh, no sir crawling around
The internet is actually evidence of a ton of these guys popping in and out of time and space from simple entertainers like
Nicolas Cage who's made appearances as far back as the American Civil War
No wait earlier as a member of the famous Habsburg family or the man
We currently know as Keanu Reeves popping in as early as the 8th century as Charlemagne yeah
Charlemagne himself whoa think it's just a Hollywood movie star conspiracy
Well think again major political figurehead Vladimir Putin mysteriously doesn't seem to have aged in over a hundred years
He's been on the planet earth and Mark Zuckerberg is mysteriously also Prince Philip the fourth of Spain
But these could all be just doppelgangers right? Mirror look-alike. Oh Peter, Dinklage really does look like Diego Velazquez
Holy cow should this episode just be about him wait wait. Don't lose focus matpat
Oh these other schmoes are just fun look-alikes from the course of history none of these Time Lord candidates compared to the most well-documented
Contestant for Time Lord status Combt de San Geman. Never heard of him?
Well let me make some introductions
Since you'll be seeing him in your past present and future from now on Combt de San Geman, or just Count of Saint Germain
For those of you who failed French class was your quintessential Renaissance man born in theory in
1691 he was reportedly the son of Prince Francis the second Rák óc zi
Rák óóc chi, Ráhk óóc si Rákóczi  Prince Francis the second of Transylvania
Which can we be honest will always be every other place for spookiest country contest it turns out that Transylvania
Isn't just Dracula's favorite destination. It's also home to some pretty creepy time travelers as well, so while our buddy Combt Germain lived there
He was a locally well-known philosopher
Artist scientist and musician that in and of itself isn't crazy since we know other people in history like
Leonardo da Vinci have been Renaissance men, but take a closer look at the counts public facing life
And you start to see there's more to this man that meets the eye a friend of his Giacomo
Casanova wrote in his memoirs that the count would regularly talk about knowing quote the secret of
Universal medicine that he possessed a mastery over nature that he could melt
Diamonds and have the ability to form out of ten
Or twelve small diamonds one large one and at dinner parties the count was known to talk about historical figures like Cleopatra
And Henry the eighth as if he knew them
Personally when sceptical historians would try to trip the count up by questioning him about tiny historical details the count would always reply with
remarkable accuracy leaving everyone
Dumbfounded by how much he seemed to know about people from completely different times and places
And remember this was hundreds of the years before modern communication and only a couple hundred years after the printing press was invented so
Everything to count knew about music philosophy medicine science and history had to have been learned one page at a time
over the course of a lifetime well that or
Experienced one day at a time as you travel through an eternal life span. So okay
He knows more than he should about a few things and claims to know the secrets of science and medicine is that Time Lord worthy?
It isn't on its own
But then consider this the really funny thing about our buddy the count is that no one really knew where he came from in fact
While it was said that he was the son of Prince Francis the second rah grah grah of
Transylvania the only person who claimed this was the count himself and when he was pressed for an answer as to his origins he told
People he was five hundred years old. I mean really imagine that conversation
Uh, Hello, where did you go to school I'm five hundred years old I was born before Universities were a thing
Oh my, I bet Greek life really blew chunks back then in my day Greek life was still being lived by the Greeks
500 years old you're really not getting this are you on top of that he claimed to have been present at very specific
historic events during his 500 year lifespan
he told people he had a room in the Tower of London in the
1300s then he claimed to have studied alchemy in France in the
1400s and even if you don't go with drunk person at a party history even the real
Documented parts of his life seemed to play into his claims according to tangible historical records that do exist he was actually born in
1691 and died in
1784 at the age of 91 now, that's a pretty amazing lifespan for someone in the 17th century
We're not just talking about one guy who lived a particularly long time in history
Instead what we're looking at is a man who's capable of going wherever he wants or
Whenever he wants during that life under tons of different
Aliases he went by dozens of different names the Marquis de Montferrat, Comte Bellamarre, Sheve Chevalier Schoening, Count Weldon, Comte Salt
Soltikoff, Graf zagrocheese Graf Jzarogy and
Prinz ra Prinz rag go Skee give up
I give up on that list just to name a few and the hardest few he was apparently
fluent in French and German spokes some Polish was learning English but was most comfortable speaking Spanish or Portuguese
Besides being able to take on all kinds of different backgrounds and names though this guy also shows up all over the place
He was Documented in London during the Jacobite revolution showed up in French court with Louis the 15th
He negotiated peace in Holland during the Seven Years War all this time
He was known as a wealthy aristocrat
Who had major art and book collections that he kept in his royal estate so when he supposedly died they found almost no
Possessions on him he did all this travelling
Participated in major historical events all across Europe met some of the most famous people in the world
But didn't keep any sort of memorabilia souvenirs nothing no artwork. No library of books no castles
No snow globe in fact the town. He died and had to auction off. What little stuff
He had six months after his funeral because no living relative came to claim any of it none of it adds up to what most
People would claim believable from one guy's lifetime
And he's still not done even after death over the years after his supposed death
He also just kept right on popping up at major historical events in 1793
He supposedly appeared at the execution of Marie Antoinette and in
1799 there was an account of him being present in the French courts during Napoleon's national coup in
1820 on the night before Charles Ferdinand was murdered the countess Adehemar reported visiting with him
In 1870 Napoleon the third was apparently so interested in this quote-unquote
"Undying count" that he had a special commission put together to collect information on it
But all those records were mysteriously lost in a fire in
1871 only one year later in
1914 two Bavarian soldiers claimed to have
captured him during World War one and on and on and on with his latest appearance being as late as the
1960s at a political conference in Berlin so Time Lords exist they're on record call it case closed everyone
We got him 14th official doctor confirmed
But not so fast honestly when I was scripting this episode many years ago and now today
This is where I wanted to end it with Time Lords existing and Doctor Who being totally plausible in real life
But while researching it I'd be lying if I didn't say I came across some ideas that cast a bit of doubt onto this whole
Time Lord conspiracy and that the episode itself felt incomplete without discussing why this obviously probably isn't a real thing
What if I could not only tell you why we think Time Lords exist?
But why we like to believe they exsist
In the first place it turns out when we create conspiracies like about Keanu Reeves having previous lives
We're actually engaging at a kind of intellectual gymnastics famous psychologist Kirby Farrell has written pretty extensively about conspiracies
And how putting together the pieces of conspiracy puzzles give humans the same kind of
Satisfaction as putting together something like a complex jigsaw puzzle or solving a difficult logic problem. It makes us smarter it
Helps us to feel more empowered
And it actually makes us better equipped to solve problems in the real world like
Programming computers building car engines and learning music in the research Farrell has done
He's actually found that people who buy into conspiracy theories aren't the wide-eyed rubes. You might think they are in fact
It's the complete opposite people who tend to love conspiracy theories like
I don't know people who watch online videos proving that their favorite
Characters from all sorts of media are secretly evil
They're not the gullible ones they tend to be the skeptics of the world whether they're cynical about something in life
Or just don't take what they're told at face value even in the face of social pressures people who look for
conspiracies tend to form their own opinions and buy into
Conspiracies on their own, does that mean the conspiracies are right most of the time no
Conspiracy theories are just that is the count of saint Germain a real Time Lord maybe and then again?
He was probably just a really good liar who read a lot of history books
Sounded like he knew what he was talking about and left a pretty hefty
Reputation behind him if you stop and look at the facts
It was actually common for nobility to go by multiple names
So they could avoid talking to people that they didn't like it was also common for them to travel around Europe and then inflate their
Stories about their own travels hashtag bragging rights there was no
Fact-checking at that time so all he had to do to convince other people he was smart was just convincing whoever was in the room
With him and all those historical accounts of him appearing after he died well several of them were from an unhinged woman who fantasized about
Him after his death the others were reporting from high-stress situations like the battlefield in World War one and political
negotiations during the Cold War when you unpack a lot of
Conspiracies you find that the majority of them are explained by simple if kind of disappointing logic
But at the end of the day my point here is that that might not actually be what matters here
What matters is that you ask the
Question in the first place that you saw evidence out there
And you didn't take your own assumptions at face value and for all you Whovians out there
Who've been waiting two years for this episode well one of the defining characteristics of that show is its constant ability to redefine your
Expectations keep you curious and keep you trying to put the pieces of the puzzle together and a person who's skeptical of what they're told
Looks for the facts themselves and comes to their own opinions off of those facts
That's the type of person this world needs now more than ever so maybe the two year wait was worth it, but hey
that's just a Theory a Film Theory aaannnnd
Cut. Hold up you waited two years for this episode and now that you've watched it
You've got a whole another month before the Doctor Who Christmas special
So what are you gonna do with your timey whiney loving selves to fill the gap how about watching?
Another
Sci-fi series about people who travel through time to save the lives of others wow that sounds a lot like Doctor Who I hear you
Saying and yes, yes it is
But it's even better because it's here on YouTube right now all you need are two words life
Line well, it's two words, but they're fused together into one bigger word
A compound word
Technically LifeLine is all about a company that sends its agents
33 days into the future to save the lives of people that they know are gonna die kind of like mini Time Lords and training one
agent fails to save his wife's life and suddenly it becomes a manhunt and
THROUGH
TIME
And not only is it a cool concept that perfectly matches your interests and Doctor Who but it's also a series done by my
personal friends Sam and Nico from the channel corridor digital who if you're not familiar have been pioneers of high quality
Effects driven videos since the earliest days of YouTube I love these guys I love their work
And I think that you're gonna love them too, so check out their new series lifeline the first episode is available right now
just wave your little sonic screwdriver up the link you see on screen or click the link in the
Description and then keep your eyes locked on the screen like it's an angel statue and heck if you like it you've got yourself eight
30-minute episodes to fill your time enough to keep you busy until the premiere of the first ever female
Doctor in December now if you'll excuse me I need to start working on another trilogy
Of episodes the third part of which will come out years after it's relevant. See you then